Learner A4: ولا عادي.
Mentor A: الو الو.
Learner A4: أيوا من السلام عليكم.
Mentor A: صباح الخير عاملين إيه.
Learner A4: الحمد لله صباح النور.
Mentor A: انت سامعني كويس صح؟
Mentor A: أوكي طيب بصو في غودنيوز كويس إن إنتو التلاتة اللي موجودين دلوقتي عشان إنتو تقريبا موجودين أكتر بالكت الإسبنتي.
Mentor A: أنا مبارح عملت عملت تريال كده
Mentor A: على اتش ام ال اللي انتوا كنتوا بعتهولي بتاع اللي هو الأوبي مشي.
Learner A4: أوكي.
Mentor A: فقعدت يعني كنت عملت كده إن أنا كونفيرت تو ام بي فور.
Mentor A: عملت تريل كده وهي زبطت يعني هي طلعتلي أوتست حلوة قوي
Mentor A: طبعا أنشأت دي كل الفايل يعني مش هدي كل سكريت طبعا يعني معلش الدوشة اللي حوالي أوكي بس.
Learner A4: كمان حاجة يعني.
Mentor A: طب كويس الحمد لله مش هديكوليسكفت أكيد أنا هسبوا انتو تجربوا
Mentor A: ماشي لحد ما بعد كده لو مثلا زي ما طلعت أنا هوريكو الأتود برضه بس مش حوريكم عملت
Mentor A: فانتوش في جروت إنتو.
Learner A4: ما هو لايند مع الفايب لاين؟
Mentor A: هو سكريبت أنت بترنوا بعد ما نطلع بترن السكريبت بتاعته عالفايل
Mentor A: أهم حاجة يعني إنت دلوقتي انت طلعت طلعت دوت اتش ام ال صح؟ مش دي آخر.
Learner A4: أوكي.
Mentor A: فايل سيفت.
Learner A4: أوكي ماشي.
Mentor A: اعطيت له الباسمال ببرميل.
Learner A4: سلامة ماشي تمام يعني.
Learner A3: يعني.
Learner A4: في.
Learner A4: ما أنا ألريدي بعت لحضرتك مبارح في الفيديو.
Mentor A: ماشي بس هو كان في قصص كثيرة.
Learner A4: في الجينيراشن نفسه مش في الكنزلا
Learner A4: يعني كومنت كانت كلها موجودة في آخر آخر حاجة أنا وصلت لها كان ماشي تمام المشكلة اللي كانت الوحيدة
Learner A4: ايوه.
Mentor A: طب ثانية واحدة عشان فيجوالز اللي انت يعني فيجوال زي اللي كان فيه مشكلة ولا إنت مش عارف ترندر فيجوالز
Mentor A: فيديو.
Learner A4: في الفيديو.
Mentor A: نعم، كنت حاسة أنا شايفة. حاجة غريبة أوي في اللي انت بعتوه البارح ثانية كده
Mentor A: طيب بالنسبة للحاجات أصلا فوق كده هل ده اصلا بسبب السين ولا ده بسبب ال راندرنغ.
Learner A4: ده بسبب
Mentor A: بسبب بسبب.
Learner A4: اللي.
Mentor A: فيديو تحول.
Learner A4: في.
Learner A4: ميرسي.
Mentor A: آخر فيديو ده في حاجة يعني هو
Mentor A: ثانية واحدة.
Learner A4: مع.
Mentor A: يعني هو في الآخر آخر الفيديو تبعتولي ده في الدقيقة دقيقة و30 ثانية حتلاقي ان هو
Mentor A: حاطط حاجات في النص وبعد كده حاجات على الشمال بيقولك فاست فيس دي مونتاج مش عارفة إيه دي اصلا لايتد بال جرين هو يتكلم بعد كده ما عملش سويتش على بعديها اللي بعديها بايل.
Mentor A: وانت مستخدم ريموشن بس صح.
Learner A4: تاني.
Mentor A: اصطدم ريشن بس.
Learner A4: موسم ، هو ريموتن الستات اللي احنا شغالين بيها ودمج.
Mentor A: ماشي هو بياخد وقتها قد مش حيطلعلك الفيديو.
Learner A4: من بعد.
Mentor A: أم.
Learner A4: بصير يعني.
Mentor A: أوكي طيب بالسوق أبعتلكوا على الغروب ولا أبعتهالكوا خليني أبعت هالكرف.
Learner A4: أوكي.
Mentor A: طبعا هو ده مش الفيديو كامل يعني أنا عملت شوية تعديلات جوا الأتش تيم إل نيكسون. عشان كنت عايزة أشوف
Mentor A: حتة الأزواج دي كأس الألميشنز.
Learner A4: أوك.
Mentor A: عشان أنا مش عاجبني خالص خالص الصور.
Learner A4: ما هو رمز.
Mentor A: مش حروح.
Learner A4: على كان في رأيي يعني اللي هو المفروض او اللي انا كنت حطيته فلان بالنسبة لي الاسبوع ده كل 1 يعمل الهانسمين
Learner A4: اللي هو شغال عليهم لأن أنا شايف اللي هو لو كل 1 مثلا مركز بس على الإيدنت بتاعه
Learner A4: يمسك ومتاكد منها 1,000,000 وتوصل للفايف لاين طبعا.
Mentor A: حطلعها بايه من الصور وحش. أنا مش عايزة أطلع صور خالص.
Learner A4: ما هو للاسف عباره عن صور وتبغ.
Mentor A: ماشي طيب أنا عايزاكوا أول حاجة قبل ما تشوفوا الفيديو الفيديو ده أنا عملتوا في بالضبط يعني ماشي خلاص أنا جبت السكرت اللي بيحول اتش سي ام ال ام بي فورد
Mentor A: فأنا جبت الإشتمال انتو بعتهولي بتاع الأوبي ده بالزبط هو هو
Mentor A: وعملت حاجتين فيه زودت عدد السينس
Mentor A: خليكي باردش أكتر في الكونت ودي حاجة أظن تطلع عادي يعني تطلع من.
Learner A4: هذه سهله دي سهلة ما فيهاش مشكله.
Mentor A: فزودت أشوف بس فزودت وعملت حادثة.
Learner A3: يعني عدم.
Learner A4: نهايه.
Learner A3: بتاع.
Mentor A: طب لو معاك أوت بتبعتهولي دلوقتي.
Learner A4: هو ألريدي ألريدي لو تاخدي بالك الفيديو اللي أنا بعتهولك. هو بتاع 6 ولا حاجة غير الأنترول أو.
Mentor A: ما ينفعش نخلي 15.
Learner A4: ماشي يا دوب العادي.
Mentor A: ماشي دي تاني حاجة عملتها ثاني حاجة بقى إننا خليت ال فيش فولت اس بي جي.
Learner A4: أو.
Mentor A: الصور شلت الصور كلها خالص وخليته إن هو يشوف الكونتينت ويعملي يكتبلي كل يرسمه طبعا كان في إيشوز يعني طبعا كان في حاجات كثيرة هو بيعملها مثلا مش عارفة ترندر كويس
Mentor A: فدي برضه أنا حطيتها يعني عملت كده زي غورد ريلز
Mentor A: وانتو بتكتبوا ال اف بي جي دي
Mentor A: تلتزموا بيها يعني مثلا ما تحطوش تستخدمه كريمز يعني الأنيميشن تبقى كريمز بس سي اس اس يعني ما نستخدمش كريفت لو هنستخدم بطريقة معينة. يعني أنا كتبت رايز كده وهبعتهالكوا برضه
Mentor A: بس من الترايل بتاعتي يعني ماشي معرفش بقى هل انت ال راندرينغ بتاعك في الفيديو
Mentor A: الحاجات دي حتمشي معاه ولا لأ يعني أنا دي عملتها.
Learner A4: هو.
Mentor A: الإيرندرنغ لامد.
Learner A4: هو اللي أنا متأكد منه لو حضرتك يعني عرفتي توصليله مبارح او التكنولوجي
Learner A4: مناسب اكتر ويقدرين اكيد يعني عادي ما عنديش مشكلة افضل ثاني من اول واحاول ان انا اعدلها عادي
Learner A4: ما فهمتش.
Mentor A: أنا كده كده مش هديكول مش هديكوا مش هديكوا يعني ممكن أديكو بس كونسبت إني أقولك بس أنا عملت بس مش يعني مش هديكوا الفيل دلوقتي حيتدربوا.
Learner A4: الرموشن.
Mentor A: لا ما كنش في كروما و اف ام بانك.
Learner A4: أساسا تم في دور.
Mentor A: من.
Learner A4: إيه.
Mentor A: كرومو بلايرت.
Learner A4: كروما وبلاي.
Mentor A: أم.
Learner A4: ماشي يا فندم ما.
Mentor A: أوكي وكان بتطلعلي إيشوز يعني كان في مثلا هو كان بيطلع الفيديو أول مرة جربت
Mentor A: كان بيبقى الصور جامد قوي يعني لا تتهز.
Learner A4: أوكي.
Mentor A: فده ده عشان عشان أنت لما تفتح يعني على كروما بتصرف على كروما ب فور وورد
Mentor A: بتايم كلوك مختلفه يعني فكل لابتوب مترن عليه ال تايم كلوك دي بتبقى على حسب اللابتوب.
Learner A4: نعم.
Mentor A: بس فكل اللي عملته عملت فريزر
Mentor A: عملت فريزر جلوك دي وبقيت أنا بنفسي كأني بنضج ال هو يمشي ستبس تايم معين
Mentor A: بنفسي عشان أعرف أزبط الفيبريشن ده
Mentor A: فطلعت في مسقط ممكن بقى أشوف الفيديو اللي أنا أبعتهالكو ده.
Learner A4: نت.
Mentor A: حرام عليكي شايفين إيه.
Learner A4: أنا بشوف وحالي.
Mentor A: إنتو معظمكم هتبقوا شغالين على الشمال.
Learner A4: ألو أنا ميتين.
Mentor A: ماشي أنا بعتلكم اللي جوا الكلام ده ممكن مكتوب إزاي
Mentor A: يعني متقسم إزاي بس أنا يعني أنا قصدت إن أنا أزيله نفس ال فاو قلت له يعدل عليه بنفس الشكل
Mentor A: عشان مش عايز حاجة من الأول يبقى أنا عندي بيز من بيدفع ألريدي من.
Learner A4: اها.
Mentor A: ماشي خليها الستريكشن بتاعت اللي مشيت معاه اللي أنا بعمله.
Learner A4: الاسف.
Mentor A: أم.
Learner A4: كانت بناء على ال كونسبت ولا.
Mentor A: لأ مش على حسب هو هو طلعها بيز على.
Learner A4: أوكي أصل أنا كنت بفكر ان احنا نحط كنسترين في تيم بلانينغ ولا أسست
Learner A4: علشان الفيزيز تبقى طالعة كده ماتش ال تيم أساسا بتاع الشركة اللي هو كاس برينتش في نفس الوقت نوحد الدنيا
Learner A4: علشان الستار اللي طلع في زي ما حضرتك شفتي البارح كان فيها مشاكل
Learner A4: هو من ألوان من برستاغرام من
Learner A4: فكنت حاسس يعني لما احنا نحط فالريزل دي بتأكدلي يعني لا كروتش اللي في النهاية.
Mentor A: أو إذا عشان لما بعملها بتطلع وحشوي.
Learner A4: لو معاكي اللبس كمان نفسه تمام يعني.
Mentor A: معايا بس برضه عشان اللي هيعمل بقى الأجنت اللي
Mentor A: اللي هيحط الكلام ده فيه كونسترنج وبيكتب أس بي الكلام ده يبقى عارف برضه اللي هو رأيكو في الفيديو.
Learner A4: لا لذيذ.
Mentor A: أوكي فأنا شايفة إن حتة بيجوالز دي صحيح؟ مش حتديكي الجامدة بحت يعني اللي هو زي حتة إنكمليشن دي لازم أطلع تل وحاجة تدخلها إلى حد ما
Mentor A: يعني أحسها أكسبت
Mentor A: وفي نفس الوقت في أنيميشنز في حاجات تتحرك مش صورة بعملها وأنزلها كدا بس يعني مش ستابيك.
Learner A4: نعم.
Mentor A: ماشي.
Learner A4: ماشي ده.
Mentor A: أوكي.
Mentor A: مرحبا بيك.
Learner A4: بلاستيك.
Mentor A: أوكي طيب مين اللي كان ماسك ال سيم كلاند باهي صح؟
Learner A4: إيه مصطفى باهي.
Mentor A: أوكي.
Learner A3: أيوه تمام.
Mentor A: عشان ييجي يشرحلك شرحالك في 3 سنين بس
Mentor A: الأول قالك هي بتعمل إيه بعد كده الصين التاني جابلك كودس نبت بعد كده الصين التاني قالك طيب واي بنستخدمها
Mentor A: البوينت لوحده اتشرحت في 3 سنين و3 سنين مرتبطين بنفس النقطة بس مختلفة يحب يقولك واي ويحب يقولك ويحب يقولك طب إيه أصلا هي أنترونيها وهكذا
Mentor A: أوكي ده طلع ألريدي ده طلع من إيه ده مش أي حاجة غير إن إنت.
Learner A3: بسيطة.
Mentor A: موجود.
Learner A3: اعرف بس حضرتك اللي حضرتك شايف انها كويسة ونعملها عادي.
Mentor A: عندك أنا محتاجة بس تطلعلي يا شئ.
Learner A3: الحاجات يعني الحاجات بتاعة ال بس.
Mentor A: ليش زي ما هتشرحها ازاي ممكن 1 2، 3، شكرا،
Mentor A: 1 تاني هيقولك 1 ويبتدي يشرحلك 1 2 ويبتدي يديك حاجة على 2 3 الفيديو اللي إنتو مطالعينه في الأول، كنتوا بتطلعوهولي
Mentor A: كان في تقريبا 3 بلوكس كده من الداتا أو 3 بلوكس فيهم حاجات وإنت بتقوليشن كذا كذا بس خلاص
Mentor A: لكن الفيديو اللي بعته ده عشان.
Learner A3: أنا عندي سؤال معلش.
Mentor A: إمم.
Learner A3: هو ده علاقته بال سيم فلانينج هو ده مش سكريبت.
Mentor A: يعني.
Learner A3: يعني علاقته بالزبط وبعد ما باخذ سكريبتعارض، ازاي لكنت نفسه لا بعمل نفسه.
Mentor A: إن.
Learner A3: أنا.
Mentor A: عدل.
Learner A3: منو وسيم.
Mentor A: ماشي عدلوها في الأستوديو الستديو لو كانت لحد ولحد تقريبا دروب أو بتاعته كان في حد عملها مكان ومين كان عملها.
Learner A4: أنا أنا.
Mentor A: أوكي ماشي ظبطها يعني.
Learner A4: في.
Learner A3: ملهاش علاقة لكن فكرة مثلا إن إحنا نقسم كونتينت على عدد أكبر من ال سينز او كده ده مفيش منه مشكله.
Learner A3: لكن السكريبت هو اللي ليه علاقة.
Mentor A: عمر هيزبط حصة بتاعه وإنت خدوا بس إعملي بالطريقة مظبوط.
Learner A4: تمام.
Learner A3: ما فيش مشكلة.
Mentor A: أوكي طيب أنا كمان في سؤال فيجوالز فيجوال ده بيطلع من ولا ده وبتحطوها جوا ال سين.
Learner A4: آي ثينك من 2 فلان.
Mentor A: قولي يا باهي بيطلع من الصين كلينر ولا بيعمل
Mentor A: بيطلع ديسكوبشن تمام.
Learner A3: بس مش مفصل قوي بحيث ان هو يعني يبتدي ياخد يعني حاجة تشتغل على ديسكريبشن يعني
Learner A3: من بتاعته مش من بتاعة ال سيمبلان
Learner A3: فلما انتو عايزيني احطها في ممكن أشوف عمرها ازاي كبرومبل
Learner A3: واحاول اضيف النواقص الذي عنده من.
Learner A4: أو.
Mentor A: عمر هو هو عمر تقريبا مش في المية بس
Learner A4: جدا.
Mentor A: عمر ما سمعناه كان بطلع مش عايزاها كده بقى
Mentor A: أنا عايزاها تنكتب إز في جي عايزاك.
Learner A3: يعني والله أعتقد ده أحسن ماشي ما فيش مشكلة
Learner A3: يعني بدل ما جنراليه ماساي جنراليا.
Mentor A: ال اف بي جي بتاعها بالظبط كده عشان يطلعوا بالشكل اللي إنتو شايفينه في الفيديو ده لما يبقى يعني لما يشتغل جوا.
Learner A3: اوكي وانا ممكن اسأله محتاج مني في الديسكريبشن بالضبط او هو عمل في ديسكريبشن يعني الدنيا مفيش مشكله.
Mentor A: أوكي هو آي ثينك هو يعني هو آي ثينك هو حيعمل حاجة ثانية بيكتب اللي هو عامله قبل كده هو يبتدي في حاجة ثانية يعني هو يعمل أجينت أكتوالي بيكتب وعمر بقى لازم ياخد في اعتباره الجاردينز اللي أنا بعتهالكه في تيكست فايل ده
Mentor A: إن هو مثلا يكتبها بطريقة معينة أو هكذا عشان نعرف نعملها راندرنغ ما يحصلش.
Learner A4: تمام.
Mentor A: غص الصيد.
Mentor A: أم فإنت يا باهي كده مين ليه هتشتغل شغال مع مين مع عمر يعني
Mentor A: عشان تشوفوا هو محتاج ويعني هو.
Learner A3: مع عمر وشغال مع عمر دروان برضو عمر درغام حيديني كونتينت وانا اقسمه منه بشكل معين وبعدين عمر خالد.
Mentor A: في.
Learner A3: ما.
Mentor A: يعني هو يجرب يقولك لأ محتاجين نعدل فإنت ترجع تعدل ففي لوك ما بينكم.
Learner A3: بالزبط تمام.
Mentor A: أوكي طيب إحنا خلصنا من أول حاجة تاني حاجة أسامة.
Mentor A: أنت كنت ماسك ممكن هتفضل في نفس الحتة مشان ما حدش حيغير اللون بتاعه يعني انت تفضل في نفس الحتة
Mentor A: شوف انت ازاي هتاخد ال وتحطها عندك بقى في إنت عملت الحاجات اللي أنا كنت قلت عليها. الكومنتس اللي فاتت
Mentor A: بتاعت ال إنتر بتاعت اللي انت تطلع ميوزك في الأول والكلام ما تتكلمش في إنتو مش عايزة كلام في الإنتو الكلام يبتدي من بعد الإنتر الحاجات دي.
Learner A6: هو المفروض كنت مزبوط.
Mentor A: مش.
Learner A4: بس.
Mentor A: ماشي أنت دي الحاجات اللي قلتها دي بلوس بقى إن إنت تشوفها انت ازاي هتأخذ دي
Mentor A: من عمر بقى يعني عارفة دي تتحط إزاي في الشمال يعني هو حيطلعها
Mentor A: أنت معينة كأنك يعني جواها مثلا خلاص ولا محتاج تشتغل بحاجة معينة عشان تحطها يعني مش عارفة الحتة دي أوي الصراحة ما عنديش فيجن أوي دي ممكن تحط ازاي.
Learner A4: أنا شايف. إن بعد الخطوة بتاعت عمر اللي هو عملها تتخزن في الباكيد اللي أنا عامله
Learner A4: و و سامع يعملها ريتيفيل من عنده.
Mentor A: ليش كان قصدي هو يحطها زي ما قلت يعني.
Learner A4: مع.
Mentor A: مثلا بتاع الصورة.
Learner A4: هيعملها ريتيفل البطارية دي.
Mentor A: ماشي خلاص أوكي دا يعني.
Mentor A: ما.
Learner A4: يعني خليه برضه يشوف يعني لو السريه دي نافعه لو مش نافع ممكن تشوف سرية ثانية.
Mentor A: ماشي أوكي.
Learner A6: تمام.
Mentor A: تمام ماشي فكده يعني مني ده البلكوت يعني دي ما فيش
Mentor A: طبعا عمر ما إنت إنت بتشتغل مع كل كده إن إنت تقريباستر بتاع الغروب.
Learner A4: معلش معلش ينفع تاني عشان الصوت كان الصوت.
Mentor A: شلتر بتاع الجروب مش إنت.
Mentor A: الموضوع ده وتشوفي إزاي هتبقى يعني.
Learner A4: الديمودي، صح.
Mentor A: أه.
Learner A4: تمام ماشي.
Mentor A: حضرتك شغال فيها لو في حاجات في يو آي والانتيشن محتاج تاخد يعني ترفاينت أو تخلصها تمام مع بقى إن إنت شغال مع يعني
Mentor A: إيدك في كل يعني إيدك مع أسامة ويوسف وأسامة قصدي وباهي وعمر يعني حاجة عندك حاجة.
Learner A4: ما ما فيش ما فيش مشكلة.
Mentor A: ماشي طيب يوسف أنا مش عارفة يوسف
Mentor A: هو أصلا كان التاست بتاعته المرة اللي فاتت طب هو دلوقتي في حد عنده مشكلة منكو. اللي أنا قلته كله تمام كلو أونلاين.
Learner A4: وأنا كمان بس يعني انا كده مهمتي اللي أنا مع كل وظبط الكريت.
Mentor A: بس في حاجة كمان.
Learner A4: أيوة.
Mentor A: لو هما أسامة وباهي ومهدي حد عنده مهدي أسامة.
Learner A3: أنا تمام.
Learner A3: فمثلا، بزبط.
Learner A6: بردو.
Mentor A: حد حد باهي. حاول تدخل ماما عمر ميتينغ عشان هو مش موجود
Mentor A: وتقول له الحاجات دي وتوري له فيديو كدا ماشي.
Learner A3: ما فيش مشكلة.
Mentor A: طيب خلاص ندي بقى ليه يوسف يوسف كان في الحتة دي ماشوفش حاجة.
Learner A4: ما هو هو رجعلي هو رجعالي وأنا قلت
Learner A4: يعني انت كنت سألت قبلها هو كان سألك نفس السؤال ده الاسبوع اللي فات.
Mentor A: أم.
Learner A4: لو هي اتعملت ألريدي رجالها علشان فهو راجعلك
Learner A4: فأنا قلت له إن الحوار عندي يعني لأن هو المفروض وهيعمل داونلود لينك
Learner A4: وفعلا دي دي ريزلت اللي أنا وصلت لها مبارح.
Mentor A: أم.
Learner A4: طيب.
Mentor A: هند ولا كلوز.
Learner A4: إيه.
Mentor A: ديسك أوبن ولا كلوز خلاص.
Learner A4: دلوقتي خلاص موجود في ال يو اي ألريدي يعني لو عملت كوش دلوقتي على ال برانش بتاعي قدرت.
Mentor A: يا ابني مش قصدي الدملود. أنا قصدي بتاعت الكمبريشن دي.
Learner A4: مع حضرتك كنت لسا قايله حالا اللي هو انت دورتي في حتة معينة وبناء عليها عرفتي تعملي النقطة دي انا بس ماسكها ماسكها او شغال فيها لأن ما اشتغلتش في
Learner A4: في الجرافيك عامة حابة كقود بس متوتر بس لو حابة انتي تديها لأسامة وأبقى أنا ماسك اكتر تمام.
Mentor A: هي دي سنة كده ملهاش أي علاقة
Mentor A: هي دي لو هتدخل هتدخل فونكشن بعد اسامة على طول يعني ممكن تبقى في نفس الكبيرة بتاعت أسامة بتدخل بعد على طول وأسامة هو اللي بيرجعلك
Mentor A: ال دوت إم تي فور.
Learner A4: ما هو ألريدي أنا؟ ألريدي عامل فويل اسمه ام بي فور ريندر.
Mentor A: أم.
Learner A4: ده المفروض هو الكلام ده كله بيخلص بيبدأ هو اللي يعملها يعني هو فياند بيبدأ يمسك كل تين
Learner A4: ويعملوا ريندر لوحده بعد كده في الآخر خالص بيجمعهم مع بعض.
Mentor A: أم.
Learner A4: بس هي ألريدي اهو؟ هي في باكند؟ أنا قصدي بس اللي هو الجزئية اللي احنا شغالين بيها سواء ودي إل أو دوم
Learner A4: أو رموش عشان كنت اشتغلت قبل كده ودي
Learner A4: بس لو شايفة اللي هو ممكن مثلا أسامة يبقى ماشي فيها اللي هو بس فيها تمام.
Mentor A: لا لا عادي. أنا أنا مش هو هي كده كده بي خلاص آي ثينك إنها يعني خلاص.
Mentor A: أنا بس مش عايزة اللي هو باخد على طول عشان أنا أشوف الفيديو اللي إنتو بعتولي فيه في إيشوز يعني في طالعة الفوق. في وهكذا هل لو عدد السنين كبر هتبقى نفس نفس كواليتي أنا عندي لما عدد السين بيكبر محتاجة في باراميتر أعمله كدا.
Learner A4: ده حقيقة أنا فاهم جدا المشكلة بس الوحيدة في يعني هو لو بتاعه كاتشر صح ملهاش علاقة بعدد ال سينز على قد ما هي لها علاقة اللي هو بيكاتشر بيها.
Mentor A: لأ يعني إضاءة.
Learner A4: حقولك
Learner A4: يعني دلوقتي لما لو احنا مثلا اشتغلنا وهو عمل كاتشن مضبوط جدا للثلاثين دول من حيث من حيث الألوان من حيث الانيميشن من حيث نفسه
Learner A4: مش حتفرق بقى لو احنا زودنا السين لأن هو في الأول وفي الآخر اللي بيبقى فارق معاه ال ميتود. أنا الكلام ده إزاي طالما الميتود إتضبطت مش حتفرق عدد السين.
Mentor A: طب أنا برضه عندي سؤال عشان أنا في حتة إن أنا أطلع فيديو دي اللي أعرفه أو بتاعتي إن أنا أو حتى اللي بيحصل عندي إن أنا
Mentor A: يعني كأني حرفان بشغل إتش تي ام ال كده بشغل إتش تيم ال تاني في الوقت وباخد عارفين.
Learner A4: ,
Mentor A: كانوا بيرسموا مختلفة كده يروحوا إيه مسرعين يعني يفلتوا بسرعة حيبان إنه هو بيتحرك.
Learner A4: يعني دي اللي طالع منها الفيديو معاكي.
Mentor A: أو.
Learner A4: ما هو أنا ما رضيتش ده لأن أنا كنت عايز على طول يعني بعد ما هو بيعمل على طول
Learner A4: يعني قبل لما أنا أوري يوزر اللي هو انت الفيديو بتاعك. جاهز لا أنا جاهز ألريدي
Learner A4: يعني بعمل الخطوتين مع بعض فأنا، مش محتاج الي انا رمي الفيديو.
Mentor A: ما هو عادي دلوقتي انت دلوقتي لو انت عملت إن إنت بتاخد سكرين شوتس بعد كده مع بعض بيبقى لوكال
Mentor A: انت ممكن تصرف على سوبة بيض اصلا فيها كدا
Mentor A: إن إنت تعمله سيرفنج على كده مش عارفة إيه وال آي دي بتاعه ما هو ممكن ترفعلوا سوبر بيس في بتاعتها مش لازم تحطه في داتابيس في ستور.
Learner A4: من.
Mentor A: الذاتبية.
Learner A4: في في سوق تفاهم. بس حضرتك
Learner A4: دلوقتي حضرتك تتكلمي على الكروتش بتاعي ولا كروتش.
Mentor A: بتاعي وأنت بتقول عايز لينك على طول بدل ما ترندر ده لليوزر في يو آي فأنت عايز لينك.
Learner A4: أوكي.
Mentor A: أنا بقولك اللينك ده عادي أنت بعد ما تطلعه لوكال دوت إم تي فور بالأبروتش بتاعي لو إنت بتتكلم عني أنا
Mentor A: بتديك ستوردج باقة كأنك بتعمل سيرف للحاجة اللوكل دي على هوست أون لاين فبتبقى اللينك بتاعه بيز مش عارفة إيه.
Learner A4: ما أنا ألريدي شغال؟ تمام.
Mentor A: مش إيه المشكلة اللي شايفها في الأول أنا مش فهماها.
Learner A4: هو حضرتك قايله اللي هو انت عملتي بلاي ألريدي للفيديو عندك عال وبل أول وبعد كده جالك صح.
Mentor A: بس أنا بعمله بلينغ مش على سكرين هو كروما بتديك إن إنت ما تشوفش بإيران مش بيفتح ويقعد سناب شوك منه.
Learner A4: أوكي يعني هو لما أنت أولا ما لقيت بيطلع اللي بيحصل بالظبط.
Mentor A: ما فيش أي حاجة. أنا بجيب البيسون كده بديله الباس بتاعه بس مش أكتر بديله.
Learner A4: تدي بتاع.
Mentor A: أيوة بس وبرن.
Learner A4: 1,000.
Mentor A: ما فيش أي وب بتنفتح ولا أي حاجة هوية كروما إنترني كأنها بترن ده أنا بشوف.
Learner A4: حلو أوي وبتاخد اد
Mentor A: يعني ممكن نقول ثري منوت.
Learner A4: مينى.
Mentor A: ويتش إز حاجة جدا يعني أنا عادي أنا معكم مارجين لحد 7.
Learner A4: أوكي طيب أنا هدوم في الفور ده وحرجع لحضرتك.
Mentor A: خلاص أوكي يعني أنا بس عشان أنا عايزة أكتب باستيبل دي تبقى يعني تتحط معاكو ولا
Mentor A: أكيد حعتبرها اعتبرها لسا مفتوحة هكذا ما تقفلتش.
Learner A4: تمام طيب ممكن نوضح بقى الدنيا دلوقتي المطلوب مني أنا مثلا كعمر بالزبط حاليا.
Mentor A: يا.
Learner A4: ال ال بريزنتيشن بتاعت ديموديو داي.
Mentor A: إمم.
Learner A4: تمام في هل في كونسترينز أو حاجة معينة حرجعلها في او كده.
Mentor A: القديمة.
Learner A4: هم بعثوا.
Mentor A: مش عارفة.
Learner A4: تنبا.
Learner A4: بس أنا بصراحة ما فتحتوش يعني.
Mentor A: لا ولا أنا بس أبص عليه يعني ممكن تاخذ أفكار ممكن تاخذ أفكار إزاي تو بريزنت ده عشان إنت مش قدامهم.
Learner A4: هو أنا ممكن. بريزنت أنا ما عنديش مشكلة إن أنا أعمل بريزنتيشن يعني مش مشكلتي هنا
Learner A4: المشكلة بتاعت معينة بيحسبوا عليها بيبقوا عايزين يشوفوا حاجة معينة في في المعينه دي.
Mentor A: ماشي ما هو إنت بالنسبة لك إنت أخاك تقريبا يعني فأنت حاول
Mentor A: مش عايزين كلام كثير يعني مش عايزين كلام
Mentor A: اللي هو مسترسل كده وكثير يعني.
Learner A3: ومين الستراكشر وأعتقد كفاية.
Mentor A: حتبتديها مثلا دي حاجة مش معمولة عشان تطلع حاجة زي كده لازم الأول لازم دي بروبليم ستاتمينت أو ال يوزر ستوري نفسها
Mentor A: ماشي فإنت دي بروبليم تبعك تبتدي يوزر ستوري طب إحنا عملنا بلاتفورم بيعملشن.
Learner A4: دي حاجات أساسية. أنا ما عنديش مشكلة فيها
Learner A4: هل هم عايزين يشوفوا حاجات معينة يعني في ناس بتبقى عايزة توريني شغل تيكنيكال اكتر لا انا عايزك توريني شغل معين اكتر يعني.
Mentor A: لأ لأ طبعا إنت هتعمل إيه كإنك ممكن تاخد سكرين ما هو إنت أصلا؟ لما تيجي تشيل بروجكت مش هتران قدامهم.
Learner A4: ماشي انت عم تعمل.
Mentor A: ريكورد ريكورد فأنت هتفتح عايزة تعمل سكرين ريكورد مثلا أنت أول ما تفتح اللي هي اللينج بيج أول ما بتفتح ال يو آي فلو بقى تكتب ممكن شوية لو ينفع
Mentor A: عارف انت لو عندك تيكست تيكس بوكس أو حاجة حتكتب اعمل زومنغ عليه شوية مثلا
Mentor A: طبعا ما تعملش شونغ لل أوت بتاعها فاكر إنت إنت كنت بتعمل كليك على البار اللي مثلا بيقولك عليه بيظهرلك الجيسن مش عايزة كده خالص.
Learner A4: ، ايوا لا ماشي.
Mentor A: توريهم بس كده وممكن يعني بلاش مثلا مثلا حتة ممكن يقعد فيها مثلا دقيقة.
Learner A4: عادة لما يتغير.
Mentor A: بالظبط يعني حاول مثلا تسرع الحتة دي إمم.
Learner A4: أنا هعملها.
Mentor A: أو وات إز عادي أيوة فاهم قصدي.
Learner A4: أيوة.
Mentor A: وكل كل ستات بقى بتقول إحنا عملنا فايف لاين بيعمل مش عارفة إيه وتبتدي كل ستب تريند طول عنها. دلوقتي هو بيبتدي مش عارفة إيه بيبتدي. أنا يطلع أس ريجي مش عارفة وبتعمل كده في الآخر بيطلعلك القطعة بس هو بعد ما خلصت نوريله بقى مثلا الفيديو
Mentor A: إنتو طلعتوا بقى فعلا يبقى سيفت أكيد يعني إنتو خلاص إعملوا تريال في تريال طلعت قرفت
Mentor A: هو ده الفيديو مثلا تمام فهمت.
Learner A4: تمام.
Mentor A: بس في
Mentor A: يسألوكو يعني ممكن حاجة حلوة قوي إن إنتو تخلصوا يعني تعملوا مانشون لإيه في الموضوع ادفانتاج ادفانتاج يعني مثلا
Mentor A: مثلا هنا الكوتة مثلا محتاجين مثلا محتاجين كوتة كان مثلا
Mentor A: مش عارفين نطلع فيديو مثلا كبير أو مش عارفين يعني
Mentor A: طيب قصدي شوف بقى بياخد تايم مثلا لو إنتو جربتوا في قلب مثلا ممكن ياخد أكسبتيبل منشانها برضه
Mentor A: إن إنت برومت اللي على طول الفيديو كويس
Mentor A: ممكن يستخدم بانه يبقى مثلا رينز يبقى يستخدم ان هو يبقى
Mentor A: لي معلومة في كبسولة والحاجات الكلام ده فين
Mentor A: هي هي دي هو ده الفلو يعني مش شايفة حاجة يعني ضيفتني ربي يفوت في السبع دقائق
Mentor A: وإنت بتقول يعني هي تمشي كده خلاص يوزر ستوري اللي أنت بتشرح الفيديو ليوزر هيتعمل إزاي مع البرودر ده
Mentor A: ادفنش في السبع دقائق.
Learner A4: تمام ماشي.
Mentor A: ما فيش حاجة ثانية.
Mentor A: آلية.
Learner A4: أوكي و ده كده بريزنتيشن وبعد ال مع بريزنتيشنز حعملهم هنتمن
Learner A4: عشان مصطفى ياخد أو صوت مظبوط.
Mentor A: بالظبط.
Learner A4: تمام وهخلص ال ريندرنغ.
Mentor A: أنا مش عارفة. هل دي أسيبها مع يوسف؟ ولا أنت
Mentor A: بما إنها هي؟ هو يوسف دخله.
Learner A4: أوكي.
Mentor A: فأنتو مش عارفة تنيناتو مع بعض
Mentor A: عشان أنا مش عارفة سايند مين عشان يبقى مظبوط يعني.
Learner A4: ما هو انا عايز اعرف بس من دلوقتي علشان أبدأ المفروض ان انا مسافر
Learner A4: عن الثلاث ده الاربع بالكتير حبقى مسافر فا.
Mentor A: الآن.
Learner A4: فينا حيبقى صعبة شوية.
Mentor A: هو سبكوا تبقوا مع بعض وساعة كمان وتقولي.
Learner A7: خلاصنا.
Learner A4: ماشي.
Learner A7: بطنه ومرته.
Mentor A: تمام هتقولي مين اللي حياخد باسكت دي طيب ثاني حاجة دلوقتي في في اتنين فاضلين أحمد عيد ومهدي مشي
Mentor A: طيب مهدي. أنا ممكن أسيبلك إن إنت تشوف إزاي تعمل بكرة
Mentor A: مش عايز بروجكت ده يبقى دي كويس عايزة سوكن تينس
Mentor A: أكيد إنت ما عندكش بتاخد دلوقتي
Mentor A: بس انت هيبقى تيست بتاعتك أصلا إيه هو داكر وبنعمل وإيه السبسي عشان بروجكت بروجكت
Mentor A: ويه تاني انت لازم لازم في الستاند
Mentor A: مثلا إنت عملت ده النهارده خلاص معاكي اليوم كله بكرة في الستاند
Mentor A: مع كله يعني تفهم الباقيين كلهم إنت وصلت لإيه تعملهم ريبورت كده عن اللي انت فهمتو وإيه اللي انت وصلتلو بتاع البورت
Mentor A: هو ده عايزة تو كونتينر كونتينر كونتينر بات أند
Mentor A: نشوف إزاي ممكن يكلموا بعض وهكذا طبعا دي حتبقى يعني محتاجة ان انت ترنها عندك ترن كل الموضوع ده كله عندك يعني ماشي
Mentor A: عوام بيرد تقريبا انت سمعيني ألو.
Learner A7: نعتذر.
Learner A4: سؤال.
Mentor A: أنا مش عارفة سامعني بقى ولا مهدي
Mentor A: ماشي طيب خلاص أنا هبقى.
Learner A2: على.
Mentor A: الله يسلمك طيب إنت سمعت أنا قلت إيه.
Learner A2: لا بصراحه السلطه.
Mentor A: ماشي أنا كنت بقول إن إنت هتمسك هتعمل الأول إنت أكيد ما عندكش
Mentor A: من الأول أولكر وإيه الموضوع بتاعه كده حتى يخليك تعمل يعني ديكوراسيون صح
Mentor A: خلاص بعدين بكرة في بلانينغ إنت معاك النهاردة كله بكرة كله سبرينت بلانينغ بتاع 5 بلانينغ
Mentor A: بتاعتك كله عمر وباهي أسامة. وهكذا على كل ده عارف نوليدج
Mentor A: يعني تعملهم زي ريكورد كده إكسبيرنيشن مثلا
Mentor A: لإيه هو داكر وازاي بنعمله وإيه سبايل وبيستعمل في وإيه الفلول اللي داكر بيستخدمها عشان يبني الأميد والكلام ده
Mentor A: ماشي وبعد كده بقى تبتدي لأنها بس 1 للباك إند و1 للفرنسيين شوف بقى بتاعك
Mentor A: إزاي بقى يكلموا بعض ما بينهم وإيه الحاجات اللي إنت محتاجها
Mentor A: ماشي وطبعا ده في برانش مختلف
Mentor A: يعني جاست كلنا عايزاه نكتب طول المين دلوقتي وتاخد منها برانش
Mentor A: تاخد برانج سميه مثلا وتشتغل فيهم
Mentor A: الباقيين عادي مش لازم نرن أبليكيشن
Mentor A: دي حاجة عارفين الدنيا بتتفرنس ازاي وكدا وتبقى عارفين عشان بروجكت محتاجة يبقى عندي وهكذا ماشي
Mentor A: لكن عيب يعني إنت عمر أنت.
Learner A2: عشانك بس تبعتيلي او تبعتها على جروب لاننا في الشارع والشبكة وحشة في كلام بيقع مني.
Mentor A: أنا مش هبعت عن جروب. أنا هبعت تذكرة. أنا شرحتها هبعت التذكرة على طول خلاص.
Learner A2: ليس هناك مشكله.
Mentor A: أنت عمر إيه عمر أنت بحاجة عادي يا جماعة إشتغلوا عادي جدا حاجة يعني اشتغلوا عادي من غير دوكر ولا أي حاجة
Mentor A: مضبوط.
Learner A4: أيوا أنا عارف عارف عارف.
Mentor A: مفيش حدادا.
Learner A4: أنا أنا عندي ذكر بس مش اللي تخليني يعني مثلا أيمن.
Mentor A: براحتك يعني دي كده حاجة عايز من المين
Mentor A: تاني وتجرب إنت تذاكر تاني بس مش تبقى حاجة من ال ديليفربز بتاعتك لو عايز أنت تجربه أي حد عايز يعمل كده براحته بس محدش الكلام ده عن مين خالص ده برانش تجربه
Mentor A: محدش خالص يبش دوكر دا علماني.
Learner A4: أكيد واخ.
Mentor A: ماشي ومهدي برضه ما تعملش عالمن دلوقتي خالص.
Learner A2: نعم.
Mentor A: لما أشوف لما أشوف أنا الأول حتى
Mentor A: بس محتاجة قبل يعني قبل ما تبعتلها
Mentor A: هو إنتو لما بتبعتوا بي ار وهي بتقلكوا أبروف إنتو بتدخلوا تعملوا مرش ولا هي اللي بتعمل أوتوماتش.
Learner A4: لا إحنا اللي بنعمل.
Mentor A: خلاص يعني إنت إعمل ال بي ار عادي عشان تتقفل ويحصلها جريدينغ ماشي بس ما تعملش نرجع لمين مهدي.
Learner A2: تمام.
Mentor A: ما تعملش نرجع غير لما ترجعي الأول أبص أنا الأول.
Learner A2: تمام ماشي.
Mentor A: ماشي الباقين زي ما قلتلكم عايزين تشتغلوا دي حاجة يعني أنا عايزة فيها ماشي عادي جدا اعملوا برنش وسموه مثلا أسامة دوكر يعني
Mentor A: وجربوا فيه بس إيه ده خلاص ده مش تاتشيد وده مش حاجة من ال بتاعته يعني مش لو سلمت يبعت بيه ولا أي حاجة
Mentor A: حتى مش حكتبها في دي هتبقى مهدي بس ماشي.
Learner A4: أوكي.
Mentor A: ماشي أوكي حد عنده أي أسئلة.
Learner A4: لا، تمام.
Mentor A: طيب الإنكاس بقى برضه دي حاجة قبل ما يا عمر إنت ويوسف إنتو بتزبطوا مع بعض
Mentor A: أي أيا كان الكاتب ماشي البتاع ما ظبطتش يعني مثلا فيجوال سي دي أو واتيفر اللي هي الحاجات بتطلع فوق وكده الفيديو، ما طلعش حلو
Mentor A: أنا معناتها هي تهزمكم تجربوا مش قلي يعني إبعتلي كده ميساج وأنا هديك لسكوت.
Learner A4: تمام.
Mentor A: عشان سيف تايم يعني وما يبقاش يلحق.
Learner A4: تمام ما فيش مشكلة.
Mentor A: خلاص تعبك كتير عشان عايزة أحط التاسكات.
Learner A4: أنا لو ينفع بس لو ينفع الطلب من كله
Learner A4: انه كله يحاول يشغل كله شغال يبقى شغال عنده
Learner A4: بحيث ان كلو يبقى فاهم بروجكت ماشي ازاي.
Learner A4: وفي نفس الوقت، يشوف الرز بتاعتو بقت عاملة ازاي.
Mentor A: يعني البلقاية في باهي وأسامة وعمر سيمكلر والقصص والاشتم قلب
Mentor A: فأنتو إنتو التلاتة اللود كله عليكوا هنا إن إنتو تطلعوا حاجة كويسة وإنتو التلاتة تبقوا بتسلموا بعض سموس
Mentor A: وعارفين تتدخلوا الدنيا مع بعض، لأن هو ده الكور أصلا يعني ما فيش حاجة ما فيش حاجة قبل الا سكريبت يعني عادي ده مش قشو
Mentor A: أنت بتطلع برا خرج برج
Mentor A: وبعديك برضه يا أسامة إنت بتاخد ما فيهوش أي ما فيهوش أي مثلا ثينك ولا أي حاجة إنت
Mentor A: فأنتو فيكو الكورد دلوقتي
Mentor A: ماشي.
Learner A4: المرسوم.
Mentor A: سامعني يا أسامة.
Mentor A: نعم، تمام.
Learner A4: إنو.
Learner A6: رسمتها.
Mentor A: نسيتن خلاص كده يا ريت برضه عشان ما فيش وقت برضه إحنا خلاص دي آخر سبرينس
Mentor A: يعتبر ده آخر سبرينتس بلانك
Mentor A: فأي حاجة يا ريت ريبورتوها على طول أنا مش دايما أدخل ولا الكلام ده يعني تبعتولي مسج على طول أسامة أول ما تطلع أو كنت إبعتلي على طول.
Learner A6: الإتش دي من نفسو.
Mentor A: يعني بعد ما بعد ما تظبط أسيت والكلام ده يعني أول ما يطلعوا على طول يبعتولي على طول كويس.
Learner A6: تمام أوكي أكيد.
Mentor A: ماشي أوكي خلاص حد عنده أي أسئلة.
Learner A4: لا، تمام.
Mentor A: كله تمام.
Learner A4: كله.
Learner A6: نعم.
Mentor A: ماشي شكرا يا شباب إن شاء الله أشوف حاجة حلوة جدا كده وتكسروا الدنيا وتبقوا تاخدوا أحسن تيم في
Mentor A: قف.
Learner A4: إن شاء الله.
Mentor A: أوكي نسينا باي باي.
Learner A4: المهم رجالة.
Learner A6: دي.
Learner A4: اي والله فين.
Learner A3: 100,100.
Learner A4: أنا مش عارف انا كنت قلتلكم تقريبا بس هو أنا حبقى مسافر فأنا من يوم الثلاثاء، بصعب
Learner A4: فلو ينفع بفنش الدنيا دي بحيث ان هو يبقى بس شغال على البريزنتيشن عشان ندي مودي يعني.
Learner A3: طبعا ما عنديش مانع انا عندي شغل كثير ما عنديش مانع ان شاء الله.
Learner A6: انا احاول برضو قدر الإمكان. النهارده كدا اتصدق كل اللي هي قالته حلول النهاردة.
Learner A4: عربية.
Learner A6: في بحيث ان بكرة بس بنوصل لحاجات ببعض. وخلصت.
Learner A3: ممكن نوصل ونشوف تمام لو عمر حاجه اللي هو دور
Learner A3: يبقى بس يرمي الكود يشوف الأرض بس يبص معانا يعني لكن ما بيكتبش.
Learner A4: هو انا كده كده أنا ما عنديش مشكلة وانا مسافر بتابع دايما معاكوا يعني أنا ما عنديش مشكلة خالص في الجزئية. دي
Learner A4: الجزئية. الوحيدة بس اللي حيبقى عندي فيها مشكلة لو في مثلا مشكلة كبيرة وحتبقى محتاجة وقت كتير
Learner A4: لأن أنا باخد الابتوب معايا النت طبعا مش حيبقى أحسن حاجة
Learner A4: تو سكرين شغال على سكرين وحدة
Learner A4: الوضع حيبقى عبثي شوية تاني حبقى ابطئ بكتير بس يا ريت يعني
Learner A4: وان شاء الله خير وان شاء الله نقفل الديمودي بتاعهم ده
Learner A4: ما فيش مشكلة يعني بإذن الله.
Learner A6: أهلا بك.
Learner A3: ومن المصلح.
Learner A6: دي كلها وأشوف ال الفكرة دلوقتي محتاجه من الأسس نفسها صح؟
Learner A4: مظبوط انا عايز لو ينفع نخش
Learner A4: يكون عمر خلص الجامعه وندخل ثاني اليوم.
Learner A3: بالليل متاخر ممكن في الليل متاخر الوصف عشره يعني دعها في الليل
Learner A3: باذن الله نشتغل او شيء نكون نهائيا.
Learner A4: أنا عايز حتى لو يعني لو هندخل نحط النقاط على الحروف لو لو بس نوصل حتى.
Learner A3: أنا معك.
Learner A4: علشان نلحق نظبط الدنيا وكل 1 عارف مطلوب منه بالضبط هو يوسف فريد صح.
Learner A4: ماشي في ماشي يا شباب.
Learner A6: ميشيل كده.
Learner A4: ولو في حاجة أنا معاك.
Learner A6: بإذن الله.
Learner A4: ماشي.
Learner A6: خالد.